we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i've got
something very special for you today
okay for years we were getting
voicemails very aggressive angry often
racist race-baiting voicemails from
someone that we identified as the kansas
troll okay
we stopped hearing from the kansas troll
for a little while then about six months
ago maybe nine months ago i picked up a
call during live calls and it was a
kansas area code and i immediately
recognized the voice and i said is this
the kansas troll and the guy said no i
guess because he doesn't even know that
he is the kansas troll but it was the
kansas troll and he tried to troll me
live and completely faceplant that it
was one of the worst face-planting of
any live troll attempt that we've had on
the show I faced palm as a result of his
faceplant it was that right shortly
thereafter he called in to sam cedars
show the majority report again total
faceplant and then we haven't heard from
him for months it's been months of
silence he hasn't at least gotten
through on live calls and i look for his
area code because i would love to put
him on but he hasn't called into live
calls he hasn't been leaving voicemails
he resurfaced in the last 48 hours with
the following beauty from the kansas
troll who is back
take a listen yes hi today i was
watching on the Dish Network channel 94
15 I believe you are talking about how
you're going to do a new miniseries
where you will be debunking different
pseudo-sciences well because your past
series I felt like there's quite subpar
I have a suggestion to make a zombie
first what you can do is you can debunk
the pseudoscience of the ground earth
model next you can debunk NASA and space
exploration by the way some other things
that you can debunk a miniseries would
be evolution you can disprove the
pseudoscience of a mechanism and then
you can also deep UNK cosmopolitan race
theory thank you so I leave that the guy
really is an uninformed ignorant person
oh yeah it's fine
I think that this is obvious trolling I
think and the reason why is that even
those who
believe in you know who don't believe in
evolution they're not usually the same
people who disbelieve some of those
other things that he mentioned right and
it's that it's I think it's just obvious
trolling and he's gone back to the
scripted trolling voicemails because of
the face-planting during live calls that
that's a genuine belief I'm glad to have
him back I'm glad he came out of the you
know the under the bridge from where he
lives to coalesce all again it's
enjoyable I think it's fun for everyone
and he doesn't really step over the line
all that often well you should hear the
voicemails we don't play now I'll send
you some of those and then we'll see if
you stick to that same point of view
so anyway Kansas troll welcome back also
people were asking about the Eggman
people saying we haven't heard from the
Eggman for a while he did leave a
voicemail recently it wasn't great so I
didn't play it but the Eggman is still
alive and well I just thought the Eggman
was on sabbatical yeah I know it's
normal that there will be periods where
we don't hear from him and we don't know
why we just don't ask I'm sure he'll be
on on the program again soon on the
bonus show today Roger stone says he's
prepared to be indicted by Robert Muller
but for what he believes will be a sort
of trumped up or fabricated concocted
charges but that is something he says he
is ready for artificial intelligence
potentially as a weapon to fight cancer
we will be talking about that and we
will also talk about what we need to
learn about boys from the violent rise
of the insel rebellion in celle
rebellion is involuntary celibacy okay
involuntary celibacy there is I guess so
there's movements that are deliberately
celibate they choose to be celibate and
then there's the involuntary celibates
who I guess it's like they can't get
dates right that's basically it what
does that mean involuntary celibacy you
don't want to be celibate but despite
your best intentions you're celibate
because you can't figure out how to not
be that's the PG way of saying it's the
PG way of saying it and it's guys who
can't get laid right that's what you're
talking about that's what we're talking
about and anyway I guess they're now
banding together in some kind of
rebellion and I am very very interested
in this I feel like it is a movement
that probably has some overlap with both
gamergate and the alt-right in some way
not and all these groups are all
all the same right but there's a Venn
diagram in which they have little edges
where they overlap yeah and also
unfortunately overlap with the Santa Fe
shooting from last week and with the
Toronto truck attack from last month
that's correct that is absolutely
correct so we'll be talking about that
and much more on today's bonus show join
pakman.com patreon.com slash david
pakman show have your pet spayed or
neutered and we'll talk to you on the
bonus show